a lot of the work you do is is with
blocks it's the
core shade for the platform samuel
jordan has been making video games since
he was 15 years old
i've gone from making clothing stores to
3d
cafes and food restaurants to now
full-fledged games
he's made all of these on a free online
gaming platform called roblox
which is available on desktop mobile
devices and xbox consoles
last year at the age of 21 jordan earned
more than six hundred thousand dollars
not yet he's among the seven million
roblox developers who've built the
company a library of over 20 million
games and experiences
and this has attracted about 33 million
daily users
and more than half of them are under the
age of 13.
the pandemic fueled this model and
roblox became a place where kids at home
could hang out
this has made it one of the most
valuable video game companies in the
world
and on its first day of trading in march
saw a market valuation of 45 billion
dollars
but as new games are created every day
the company faces the challenge of
moderating its platform
and its business model writes on whether
roblox can remain a safe place for
kids my daughter's obsessed with roblox
i know this platform
way too well she loves royal high
sarah needleman covers the video game
industry for the wall street journal
and she's been spending a lot of time on
roblox with her daughter
i got this yesterday and even owns a
copy of the ultimate guide to roblox
all of the games on the platform have
been made by
users and some are just individuals like
you and i but the company itself doesn't
make the games that are on the platform
this means roblox doesn't have to rely
on hollywood-like budgets and rockstar
talent to produce blockbuster titles
for example one of last year's most
anticipated video games was cyberpunk
2077
a game that cost polish company cd
projekt more than 300 million dollars to
develop and market
just compare that with roblox which
provides a free developer toolkit for
anyone interested in creating content
for it
luckily roblox has a lot of these
pre-made for us so we're just going to
go into our toolbox and find one
you don't have to be an expert in coding
to make games for roblox
there are step-by-step resources and a
lot of it's drag and drop
somewhat turnkey you could say so that
has made it
very attractive to younger folks who are
just sort of learning how to do this
stuff
roblox says it's continually updating
the toolkit this helps developers make
engaging content so its players don't
get bored
they can make higher quality games and
the kind of games that
adults would appreciate more so than
youngsters they're more complicated
they're more challenging
this creates an ecosystem of players and
developers just look at samuel jordan
it felt just really inspiring to think
wow at a young age i can make something
he first started playing in 2011 and
four years later he began creating his
own worlds
like fairy tale yay a new friend
today he's building complex games for
young children and even took a break
from college during the pandemic to
focus on roblox with his friends
jordan was also hand-picked by the
company when he was 19 years old to help
expand the toolkit
they've also increased the amount of
textures you can add in game and it's
really helped to
really build an atmosphere for your
games games are free to play on roblox
so jordan only starts to earn money when
a player spends the in-game currency
called robux
earning money on roblox is actually a
pretty easy process people will pay you
with robux and you can exchange those
out for dollars or your local currency
so players can link their accounts to
credit cards and for young children
they can use prepaid gift cards with
robux they can buy this prince jacket or
pay for a pass to visit the dream
mansion
jordan also makes money from
collaborations with brands
turning real world products into roblox
items but he doesn't get to keep all the
money
developers receive seventy percent of
the road bucks spent in their games
and get thirty percent of the road bucks
spent on items they put up for sale
roblox says the rest goes to running the
business including hosting services and
operations
as players flocked to roadblocks during
the pandemic the company said its
revenue last year grew 82
while sales of virtual items more than
doubled to about 2 billion
but user loyalty hasn't translated into
profits
the company has incurred net losses
since its inception in 2004
and last year those losses exceeded 250
million dollars
in part because of higher operating
costs
but profitability isn't the only
challenge there's been an increasing
amount of adult content on some games
all the sorts of bad actors you see on
social media you would have to assume
could happen on a site like roblox the
only difference is that roblox happens
to appeal to a very young audience
who's probably you know youngsters are
more vulnerable to
bad actors than adults maybe and so it
raises the bar
in terms of moderation roblox said it
hired more than 2 300 content moderators
while inappropriate words are replaced
with hashtags
the company also said it's now
developing content ratings for games
and making parental controls easier to
find and use
but as countries emerge from the
pandemic roblox hopes the habits of
using the platform aren't easy to break
even jordan says he'll continue to
create
i don't think i'm going to be chasing to
keep people on past the pandemic i'm
going to continue to make content
i think players will enjoy and the ones
that stay along are going to be there
because
they enjoy the time they spend